yeah thanks am i audible on the mic yes
okay so yeah I thank you for the
invitation it's it's a it's great to be
here as a Christa mentioned I'm I'm
local so it's also nice that I could cut
down on registration costs by limiting
travel expenses yeah so I want to talk
about something I know well I personally
find very exciting and and honestly an
area in which progress now has slowed a
bit and it's pretty clear that the the
that we need experts in quantum
information theory and quantum
computation to to push the progress
forward so let me start to sort of back
at the beginning combinatorial
optimization I know there's a varied
background of people in attendance so
let's look at the one of the classical
problems in theory of computation which
the Traveling Salesman problem so you're
given n cities and some costs to travel
between them and the goal is to is to
minimize the the cost of travel you know
visiting every city and returning to
your starting point okay so like here's
a picture of a tour on seven vertices
the blue highlighted edges are the tour
and yeah and so if you if you give in a
cost function you can think about
finding a tour that minimizes the cost
that's a classical np-complete problem
and well here's a quote from John Carlo
rota which is that you know sort of the
theory of polyhedra lay untouched since
the time of our committees until these
computer scientists started studying
discrete optimization and then sort of
field made a bit of a resurgence and I
guess there's I mean if you're if you're
somewhat younger and you don't remember
Archimedes
then there's also a hate Hollywood movie
about the Traveling Salesman problem
that came out a few years ago okay so
now the movie poster is blocking
Giancarlo rodas quote but he was very
prescient because indeed most of our
understanding or very significant piece
of it of the Traveling Salesman problem
comes from understanding polyhedra so so
by the way if you're not familiar this
thing over here is a picture of a poly
polyhedron it's just the contacts all of
a finite set of points in RN and the way
that it's related to the Traveling
Salesman problem you can associate a
very natural poly tope so think about
all the points in n choose two
dimensions
corresponding to subsets of edges in the
complete graph there are tours ok so all
of the take all of the indicator vectors
of tours so you just put ones on the
edges of a tour and take their contacts
all that's the TSP poly tope and the
reason that in computation we care about
polyhedra is because well there's a very
rich theory of linear programming which
says that we can optimize linear
functions over over polytopes now TSP is
an np-complete problem but now here
we've written it as an optimization over
a polytope so you know he's given the
costs it's not hard to check that you
know the optimal solution is the
minimization of this linear functional
over the TSP polytope and so now you can
ask why doesn't this prove that PZ will
the NP if we have efficient algorithms
for linear programming and it's because
sort of the generic algorithms for
linear programming say based on interior
point methods they run efficiently but
it's time polynomial in the number of
facets of the polytope so the facets are
the faces of highest dimension sort of
the for this three-dimensional polytope
their two-dimensional faces are the
number of facets and okay this is not
unexpected that the Traveling Salesman
polytope has exponentially many facets
and therefore you know you can't just
plug this thing into an interior point
method solver and expect to get
something efficient and in general you
could sell the same story for many
np-complete problems and it's not
particularly surprising
you can't solve them by linear
programming you can't prove P is equal
to NP just in the obvious way but if you
started this story a little bit
differently say with the minimum
spanning tree problem okay so they again
have n CDs and costs between the cities
and now your goal is to find the instead
of a finding at or just the spanning
tree and from undergraduate algorithms
class actually we know this problem is
is actually in P there's a polynomial
time algorithm there's a core okay I
jumped the gun there there's a the
corresponding you know a polytope which
is the convex hull of all the indicator
vectors of spanning trees and since this
problem is in P you might expect that
the story would have a different end but
no again this poly tope has
exponentially many facets so so far
doesn't seem like we've gotten anywhere
but it turns out that the complexity of
this poly tope is just an illusion it's
actually this positive is actually the
shadow of a much simpler poly tope
sitting in a higher dimensional space
okay so it's it's known that the
spanning tree poly tope i has a lift in
n cube dimensions that has only order n
cute facets so the poly tope itself has
exponentially many facets but it's the
linear projection of the poly tope with
only a small number of facets and as
i'll say on the next slide that if you
can optimize over the lift if you can
optimize over the poly tope upstairs you
can optimize downstairs so I mean this
is a nice it's a cute structural result
that you can you know you can write the
spanning tree value as a projection of
something much simpler in a higher
dimensional space but actually if you
think about the algorithm that this
encodes it's something very
sophisticated because what it basically
says is you can pass to a higher
dimensional space and then you can
define a geometry on this poly tope
upstairs so that continuous optimization
gradient descent upstairs actually leads
you to a solution of a combinatorial
problem downstairs okay so okay so
and in general sort of based on this
this idea you can define sort of a
general theory of say linear programs
and linear programming relaxations of
polytopes so here's the formal
definition of a lift it's just what I
said
a lift of P is
is a polytope that linearly projects to
pee and it's not hard to check that if
you can optimize over the upstairs over
Q then you can optimize over P okay just
as a note from the point of view of
people designing linear programs so if
the number of facets live corresponds to
the number of unique qualities and and
the lifting process itself just
corresponds to adding new variables to
the linear program okay so you're adding
new variables gives you some new some
more express ability and it might be the
case that with many fewer inequalities
now you can express the constraints you
were trying to express so now there's a
there's all well this is sort of there's
a whole field devoted to studying this
so it makes sense to talk about not the
intrinsic complexity of a polytope P but
it's sort of in its natural presentation
but it's extension complexity which is
the minimum over all possible lifts of P
so the extension complexity of a
polytope is small if it's the shadow of
a polytope with a small number of facets
and then we have lots of examples where
you can get an exponential savings by
passing two lifts so where the the
natural polytope underlying a set of
combinatorial objects has exponentially
many facets but these things are shadows
of simpler polytopes
let me mention two things first of all
this is a remarkably powerful model of
computation especially when you allow
approximation I'm not going to talk
about approximation very much but you
can imagine what it means in terms of
lifts you sort of you would like to say
project inside the body downstairs and
then if you enlarge a little bit
upstairs you would like to contain the
body downstairs and then that's not
quite an accurate description of of what
you should do but it's close enough for
the sake of the talk and like there are
actually sort of entire books on
approximation algorithms via then your
programming where really the books are
just studies of this model of
computation and their application - so
getting close to sort of the solution to
np-hard problems so it's a very powerful
model on the other hand you know well if
you don't expect it P is equal to NP you
don't expect that you should be able to
prove P is equal to NP so if you if you
had for instance small list of the
Traveling
polytope that would essentially show
that something a little bit weaker than
the fact that P is equal to NP so I
don't expect it they exist okay so this
field is sort of a goes by the name of
extended formulations and if you let me
just give you a very brief history of
what happened there this is very
truncated missing fifty hundred
references but in the 80s there was a
fellow it's not a person named fellow
it's actually means a like a fellow I
feel like he got enough bad press so I'm
not saying his name anymore
who yeah he tried to prove that p is
Eagle nine P by giving a small linear
programming formulation of the GSP
pollito so it had n to the six
constraints he sent it to stark the
referee
obviously I mean it was a paper that
sort of you know okay people wanted to
find a bug in it the referee found the
bug the paper was rejected and then in
the next stock he sent an updated
version with a linear program that
answered the twelfth constraints again
claiming at P is equal to NP again the
referee found the bug and the paper was
rejected and something really remarkable
happens so Mahalo Siana caucus was the
referee and he just proved that actually
not this such an approach could never
work to prove that P is equal to NP so
he he showed that no symmetric linear
program for TSP can have polynomial size
and all of the things that this fellow
in was trying to do we're giving
symmetric linear programs I feel like
this is this this is sort of a little
bit unheard of and maybe oh you know
maybe we can't do this anymore because
we're afraid of like approaching P
versus NP but it's a it's not usually
the case that you can prove an
unconditional lower bound for in a
computational model where there's lots
of interesting algorithms so this was I
mean I think it's a really impressive
thing that the me Hollis did so then
about twenty years passed and a
different set of people attempted to
prove that P is equal to NP but now
giving an asymmetric family of linear
programs for TSP okay so I'm not saying
what symmetry means but
it's basically that the the programs
respects the underlying symmetry of the
TSP problem when you permute the cities
and then just you know shortly after
that in this fantastic paper of Fiorini
at all which I believe that I think
Ronald talked about that q IP a few
years ago showed that actually you know
Caucasus result can be extended to any
linear program so the traveling salesmen
polytope is not at any small
sub-exponential size LP formulation and
it's a bit of a joke here because it
would seem that crackpots are driving
driving scientific progress but but I'm
pretty sure that that that Ronald and
friends were not were not motivated by
the 2011 yeah free prints okay so let me
mention two more results I in this area
so a couple of years ago with Xuan Chen
Prasad Ragavendra and David store we
proved that there actually there are
some problems some natural problems that
polynomial size LPS cannot solve even
though small s DPS can solve them and so
one problem is is a one side problem is
max cut in this model no polynomial size
linear program can get better than a
factor of two for max cut which is kind
of a trivial bound what I mean is
computer a solution which is better than
within factor two of optimal even though
the famous SDP algorithm of government
in Williamson can do much better okay so
this is nice it gives some gap between
the the power of linear and semi
definite programs and then clearly
progress is very fast here
a year later actually it's almost
ruffles really completed beyond our
caucuses program this is sort of the I
think the ultimate thing that Jana
caucus would have liked to prove there
which is that them even the matching
poly tope does not admit sub-exponential
size ALP characterizations and if you're
sort of a history buff of computer
science this is pretty fantastic because
you know the the P versus NP question I
mean one of the papers that really sort
of started to cement it in people's
minds was a paper of Edmonds on the
matching poly tope where he showed that
matching actually has a polynomial time
algorithm
based on using an exponential size LP
formulation okay so so really this you
know this field is a okay it's in good
shape and there's a natural question if
you you know hang around in these
circles which is what about semi
definite programs so now first of all
you don't know what a semi definite
program is let me tell you what the
model is and try to tell you why it's a
important question okay so let this SK
be the the cone of K by K positive semi
definite matrices and then a spectra
he'd run is the intersection of this
cone with with some affine subspace okay
so here's a picture of a spectra hydrant
this is the lip top sits in three
dimensions so spectra Hedra are
precisely the feasible regions of SDPs
and this is not a polytope if you can
see I mean you can see that it's curved
as you would expect the cone of positive
semi-definite matrices you know it's not
bounded by some finite number of hyper
planes and then you can define a sort of
a corresponding theory which is that the
PSD lift size of a polytope is the
smallest spectra he'd Rijn that projects
to that pollito we're measuring things
in terms of this parameter k4 I will
call K the dimensions sometimes perhaps
on accident even though the dimension of
this space is really something more like
k times k plus 1 over 2 but ok so these
model is more powerful so you know you
in with PSD lifts you can implement all
of the polyhedral lifts there is a
reason that semi definite programs are
special well there's a reason we think
they're special assuming the unique
games conjecture which is this sort of
one of the major open problems in
complexity theory you you know if if
semi definite programs cannot solve
constraint satisfaction problems like
max cut and max 3 set actually under
this conjecture there's a way to take
this hardness against one particular
model and convert it really into
computational hardness which says that
no efficient algorithm can do better
so this is sort of a powerful connection
it's conjectural between SDPs and all of
the fission computation and okay and
sometimes you can do better for
polytopes with SDPs than with with
linear programs so actually this the
ellipse up here is one example if you
project it okay it's not really Daleks
to the side
it doesn't matter everything is
symmetric it's just four so I didn't
want to block your view this thing
actually projects to the unit square the
unit square has four facets the this
polytope and and that's the best you can
do with the polyhedra lift and with an
SDP you can do something of size three
you have a three dimensional SDP okay so
at least there's a gap of three versus
four there are gaps that grow sort of
you can as a sort of so there's a what
is okay so here you should instead of DV
should make of n so there are graphs
that grow with and the parameter of the
underlying problem but the real power of
these things where we we know that
significant gaps exist is that for
approximation problems now we know that
that s DPS can be exponentially more
efficient than linear programs so for
max cut in this recent work of Qatari
American ragavendra they showed that no
sub-exponential sized linear program can
do better than factor two for Mexico
even though the Gomez Williams and SDP
gets gets much better than factor two
okay so now the question that you might
ask is okay can semi-definite programs
prove that p is equal to NP again it's a
very powerful model of computation the
methods for linear programs for
understanding their power didn't seem to
work at least you know after a few years
of effort okay and so that's the main
thing I'm talking about today which is
that it's it's not the case so SCPs
cannot prove that P is equal to NP so
this is joint work with Prasad
raghavendran david store from 2015 so
first of all we prove that for many
polytopes associated to np-complete
problems you cannot write small semi
definite programs for them okay so this
exponent is really small for sitting in
the back
something like it's it's exponential and
ends the 211th okay so so that so that
you cannot prove P is equal to NP and we
also prove some results for
approximation problems if you consider
constraint satisfaction problems then
polynomial size SDPs are are no stronger
this term is undefined because we're
gonna define on our next slide they're
equivalent ^ a very specific family of
semi definite programs called sum of
squares relaxations and you'll see where
it comes from in a second and so for
instance using that you could show that
no polynomial size semi definite program
can do better than a 7 you know achieve
a 7/8 factor approximation to max 3 set
okay so assuming P is not equal NP
famous result of hosta says that you
can't do better than this in this model
semi definite programming though which
is which is very powerful and is you
know the model for designing
approximation algorithms you can say
that actually unconditionally in
polynomial size SDPs you cannot you
cannot do better than 7/8 okay and
what's the connection to quantum so you
were gonna see it now the basic idea is
that starting with a small semi definite
program for some problem we're gonna
find an equivalent semi definite program
a very special form that people by
different names have been studying for
20 years now and then you'll be able to
understand the model of semi definite
program through this connection okay and
and the way we're gonna do it and this
is a bit well you should be skeptical
because I like this slide would get
trapped in your spam filter as P as P
equals NP and quantum and like there's
like machine learning I guess you you
guys already maybe this could also be a
pitch for like 100 million in venture
capital funding though okay so uh yeah
so let's okay so let's try to explain
now the connection and why I'm calling
these quantum learning okay so to do
that we need to look at some model of
communication okay so it's a
communication problem between two
parties nothing
very creative here Alice and Bob there's
some function that they want to compute
this is a function that takes
non-negative values so this is not a
zero one valued function there's a sum
domain a for Alice's input some of the
main B for Bob's inputs and there's a
function which is taking non-negative
values they want to compute so it's a
very simple model of communication Alice
looks at her input
she sends Bob a message Bob does some
computation outputs an answer
so it's one-way communication things are
a little tricky because of the of the
model of what it means to compute F here
so the so Alice how you know can can use
some random bits to generate this
message and Bob can use some random bits
to generate his output and here are the
constraints
Bob outputs a random number based on his
input and the message that's not
negative and an expectation is equal to
the function f okay so this is sort of
the model of computing an expectation
like so it's a it's a sort of weaker
constraint obviously than computing f
exactly and for some problems it's
significantly weaker so you can think
for instance suppose that Alice and Bob
each get two strings and they want to
compute the Hamming distance between
them so in this model alice could just
sample a random bit of her string send
that the name of that bit and the value
of that bit to Bob and Bob can check
whether it equals his value and then
output one if it does and output zero
otherwise and then you can it's easy to
see an expectation there computing the
fraction of bits on which their inputs
differ so with only log n bits of
communication just enough to describe
the name of one of the N bits they
compute the Hamming distance in this
model so it's a it's a both maybe you
know it's it's strong model and also
also sometimes surprisingly weak what's
the connection between this and and and
polytopes
so here's a communication problem given
any polytope so here's this is a
polytope e think about any any half
space that bounds this pollito so what I
mean here it is a pair it's a vector
n-dimensional vector V and a number B
and I want it to be that
the inner product for every point in the
polytope the inner product with v is
that most be okay so V is the normal
vector to this this hyperplane and B is
just describing the shift along the
normal direction and then I want to also
consider vertices of this poly tope and
the idea is that Alice is gonna get a
constraint sort of Alice is gonna get a
half space such that all of you know so
the polytope is on one side of that half
space and bob is gonna get a vertex and
actually for the sake of the talk we're
only going to consider polytopes where
the vertices are 0 1 to the N so you can
just make that change now Bob gets a
number Bob gets a vector in the discrete
cube and then their goal is to compute
this distance so the distance from the
point that Bob gets to the hyperplane
that Alice gets ok and since the point
is always in the polytope this is always
a the function is always non-negative
this is called the slack of that
constraint it's sort of you know this is
some the half space gives some linear
constraints and this is how how much
slack there is in satisfying that
constraints okay so it's a non-negative
function and you can think about
computing it in this model and I guess
since since Microsoft is hosting the
conference I should draw some of their
technology they did that it does that it
did automatically this was pretty like I
didn't have to that's not hard coding ok
what's the connection here it's actually
really beautiful if Alice sends Bob an M
big classical message and they're able
to say compute this this slack function
for all of the inputs again in this
model of computation expectation then
the polytope has a lift of size 2 to the
M so it's the shadow of something with 2
to the M facets and ok up to round up to
a factor of 2 because I didn't want to
put floors and ceilings here this is
tight so the positive has a lift of size
to them if and only if there's an N bit
communication protocol with classical
messages what about SDP is well ok so if
Alice sends Bob and said an M big
Quantum message I am qubits and they're
able to solve this problem I'll say
exactly what it
it needs a solvent in a second it's what
you would expect but I'll write it
formally that can be done if and only if
the polytope has a semi definite
programming formulation of size 2 to the
M okay so this communication model
exactly captures the model of linear and
semi definite programming formulations
for the underlying poly tope so what is
this based on it's a Jana Jana caucuses
factorization theorem together with the
rework of the theory nee at all to see
that this holds and so yeah so the let
me let me skip for a second there I was
gonna give some some reason that you
okay let let me let's let me just say it
anyway so okay I'm not gonna prove that
this connection holds so but here's some
intuition about why it holds at least in
the classical in the in the setting of
classical messages so suppose the
polytope itself had a small number of
facets okay and then I want to give a
communication protocol but though it
seems like they're trying to output you
know some real number and expectation so
I just want to give some indication of
how they could possibly exchange
messages on finite numbers of bits and
exactly compute that real number so
suppose this probably took we had a
small number of facets okay so now these
green things are the normal vectors to
the facets and there's only a polynomial
number
so by Farkas lemma in optimization the
nor you know if I have any half space
such as the polytope lies on one side of
it then the normal vector this to that
half space so that or actually the pair
V comma B can be written as a
non-negative combination of the of the
green normal vectors okay so that so
every you know every every input that
Alice gets can be written as a
non-negative combination of a polynomial
number of vectors coming from the facets
so what that means is that basically
Alice can just you know given her
constraint she can just choose one of
the facets with probability proportional
to its coefficients in that convex
combination and then send Bob the name
of that facet since there's only since
there are only say if they're only to
them facets and the name is encoded in M
bits
and then Bob will just output the the
slack on that on that facet sort of okay
and now you can check since since the
normal vector was a convex combination
of of the normal vectors an expectation
they compute the correct thing okay so
that's okay and by duality this goes the
other way and and so on but the point is
now what we are our study reduces to
thinking about this communication
problem and just okay so yeah so two
notes first of all you might think you
know okay one there's this one-way
communication model where there's
arbitrary communication so it turns out
that in this model of communication
expectation it doesn't matter this this
is a result of a I'm not sure I know how
to say this fellow's name Kenny what you
want to help Ronald can use Kenny as ski
janeski can yes key okay that's Kanaskie
shortly and and Ronald the wolf showed
that actually one-way communication
arbitrary communication are the same and
so okay so this gives you a sort of an
understanding of of what what LP and SDP
lifts are in this model they just
reduced the questions in some
communication setting and now I want to
consider a very special form of
communication okay
where Alice is a big dictatorial I'm
calling it sort of hapless Bob so Bob is
not going to get to do anything
interesting in this in this in this form
of protocol so what's the protocol let
me describe it first classically Bob has
this bit string okay and let's say a K
hapless Bob protocol or a query protocol
is is where Alice just says Bob here are
the names of some bits I'm gonna specify
K bits and here are the values I want
them to have and what you should do is
look at your input in exactly those K
bits if they match those values output a
1 and otherwise output a 0 that's that's
what I mean by a capitalist k hapless
Bob protocol Alice just tells Bob
exactly what to do and then he follows
it and outputs 0 1 based on whether
alice is
guess for those bits was correct or not
okay so it's really you know Alice sends
a a specification of K bits write the
number of the length of her message
needs to be log of n choose K so it's
about K log n bit message she and Bob
just outputs one if they if they imagine
zero otherwise and it turns out that
this special kind of protocol if you go
back to this connection corresponds to
what are called schwa leeadams lifts of
the underlying poly tope so it's a very
particular family of linear programs
which we know for instance if you take
them larger and larger they converge to
the you know to being tied relaxations
but it's a it doesn't really matter
they're not gonna play a great role in a
talk and if Alice does the same thing
but instead of specifying K bits she
specifies K bits in superposition okay
I'll say what that means in a second
then that happens that that sort of such
a protocol exists to solve the problem
if and only if the polytope has what's
called a sum of squares lifts of degree
at most 2k and again a sum of squares
lifts it's a special family of sdp lifts
that can sort of be that are kind of
generated in a formulaic way and people
have studied these for for quite awhile
let me just say what I so this is by the
same paper of can I have ski troy and
ronald and let me just say what it means
for ours to do this basically Alice
sends some superposition over the names
of subsets of K bits and the value of
she wants to see in those bits then Bob
just computes in some unitary way sort
of you know whether you know you know
for every red you know for every thing
in the superposition was Alice's guess
correct and then Bob does say some
computation and measurement that doesn't
depend on his input so the input X only
comes in through Bob doing exactly what
Alice told him to do but now in
superposition okay so that's what it
means to do it sort of with K bits in
superposition and the reason that this
is a it's sort of an interesting set of
things is that while communicate that
well this model especially in the
quantum world we don't understand very
well for the special case of these query
protocols actually
people have been studying this you know
in for instant proof complexity going
back to grigoriev for 20 years
okay so the special case when when
Alice's really just sends Bob K bits in
super the names of K bits in
superposition and Bob just sort of
haplessly follows along we understand
those models very well okay so now if we
want to understand the general problem
because it's equivalent to understanding
semi definite programming lists of the
polytope here's a maybe naive but sort
of straightforward idea let's try and
take any quantum protocol for this
problem and convert it into a protocol
this special form where Alice just sends
Bob K bits in superposition and he just
you know you know in a quantum way sort
of computes the sort of whether she was
correct in superposition and then and
then does some measurements okay so
that's that's the that's the basic idea
and here's a very simple way to think
about doing it you could just try to
implement some translator that gets
Alice's messages right alice is sending
a Bob some arbitrary say M bit messages
you could just have a translator which
translates those messages into into
messages for some hapless Bob right so
like he takes Alice's messages he
translates them into a message which
which just say look in these small
number of bit positions and look for the
following values and then you know sort
of there's some hapless Bob sitting at
the other end who just carries this out
okay so like if you had such a compiler
which would take an arbitrary protocol
or such a translator and then you know
you could implement this translator in
the middle and it was a high enough
quality right then you proved that for
the problem under consideration general
protocols and these query protocols are
essentially equivalent and if you go
back to this model of coming from
Mathematica optimization this shows that
at least for certain classes of problems
general semi-definite programs are only
as powerful as the sum of squares semi
definite programs but the point is here
though now everything reduces to just
understanding sort of well okay I mean
this is many possibly many approach to
this problem this is a
girly like naive one it's not clear why
it should work just to implement this
little translator but if we could do it
then we would whenever we can do it we
can't classify the strength of this
model by relating it to the
communication model in which Alice and
Bob are participating in some very
simple interaction okay so okay so let's
see here here's one strategy for trying
to implement this this isn't the natural
one that you might take it's a you like
try to be smart you know and like figure
out what's happening alice is sending
some quantum message to Bob and then
maybe you know sort of if you look at
the outputs given that message then
there you know sort of the outputs
depend in some way more strongly on some
bits and others and you can try to do
various clever smart things by the way
it's quite possible that people in this
community can do it although like a Toma
Varrick and an R algo Mecca and I are
currently working on an approach like
this and it's it's a it's very difficult
to be smart I guess it's a general rule
for existing in the world it's not so
easy
so we tried with my co-authors David
Prasad to be smart for a long time and
failed okay so here's the second
strategy which is like you know like
Google apparently you know they you know
they use deep learning to build this
alphago that can beat world class go
players but they don't really have any
idea how it works like they you know at
least that was what you know you know I
mean so like you know if so maybe we can
just kind of try to build Bob without
really understanding what this protocol
is doing I don't know like that's what
like if you read the New York Times
about machine learning it seems to be
what people can do you just do something
and then you get an answer and the hope
here would be that you can design say a
learning algorithm in such a way that
the outcome of learning algorithm is
actually like you know the you you sort
of learn some simulation of say of Bob
and the outcome is something that
happens to be hapless like happens to be
one of these special types of Bob's okay
so okay let's try to
understand what that means so it's oh
yeah this is the approximation of blob
which is an approximation to Bob okay so
in order to talk about this
approximation problem we need two things
first of all how are we gonna encode Bob
okay so you can encode Bob actually as a
as a quantum classical state so it's
sort of it's two parts one is just a
classical sort of variable X and then
there's some density matrix that that
corresponds to the part of Bob's world
that is quantum and here is a key thing
this is actually where the size the semi
definite program comes in or in this
model the the length of Alice's message
comes in it turns out that that if if
Alice and Bob successfully can solve
this protocol then the then Bob has
nearly full von Neumann entropy so say
in a different way the relative volume
and entropy between Bob and the
maximally mixed state is very small
what's the reason for that basically if
the function they're trying to compute
is red is relatively well spread out
then then sort of you know on various
you know on every X Bob is tending to
output you know with values between zero
and one
so the point is that Bob is actually
outputting something that has a lot of
entropy so where is the entropy coming
from well it's coming from him and it's
coming from Alice's message Alice's
messages only M bits so Bob must be
generating the rest of it and so that's
why you get this property okay but this
is really where the fact that there's a
short message is coming from if we
encode Bob like this then this state has
very very high von Neumann entropy so
let's record that somewhere and then the
the other notion we need is what's the
notion of approximation and it's enough
that Alice cannot distinguish Bob from
the approximator right because you know
like if Alice you know if like if if you
approximate Bob by some Bob filled and
Alice can't this figure out which one
she's interacting with or you know then
then our proxy at the only notion of
approximate
it matters like nobody's looking at the
source code of Bob to figure out if our
approximation was good enough okay so
and if you think about it what you can
encode sort of you know the fact that
Bob is like our approximation or any any
state fee is getting things correctly by
a sequence of measurements that are
generated by Alice okay and their gender
their elements that are that are have
the same sort of quantum classical
decomposition as Bob State okay so let
me like go over it okay so let me okay
so so so here's the again so here's this
sort of the approximation problem yeah
so we have a bunch of tests that alice
is doing you can think about alice is
interacting with bob they have to output
some answers that are given you know by
the by the function f they're trying to
compute so there's a bunch of
measurement she's doing a bob state that
have to have certain values and the
measurements are all of this form and
now what you can say is if i only care
about these measurements i don't care
about the specifics of bob and how these
implements I just care about having the
same input-output behavior what's you
know which and if my goal is really to
get some Bob that's particularly simple
because I want to I want to be able to
simulate this arbitrary Bob by some Bob
it does something as simple as possible
then there's this you know there's this
principle of maximum entropy which says
that you know if you're given a sequence
of like observations about the world
then the best hypothesis subdue those
observation is the one that maximizes
the entropy and this is like sort of
like to avoid overfitting you know if
you maximize entropy subject to your
constraints then it makes sense that
there are you know for all the other
constraints that don't say anything
about you're above the solution you're
you're sort of you're not overfitting
you're not sort of like you know because
you're maximizing the entropy okay you
can think about this is a whole
beautiful theory around it so here's an
optimization you can write down let's
maximize the entropy or equivalently
minimize the relative entropy from our
state to the maximum mixed state subject
to the set of tests that Alice by
interacting with Bob subjects them to
and if you think about what we're doing
the assumption is that Bob is doing a
decent job himself in satisfying this
protocol oh by the way yeah we should
insist that we get is makes well we can
at least apply the relative entropy to
it so we insist that we get a density
matrix a positive semi definite matrix
of trace one equivalently you can think
about the following I mean Bob is
solving this correctly so you can really
say that on all of these tests a 1 a 2
and so on
I want the approximator and Bob to give
about the same answer ok so this just
says that the approximator
should in terms of input-output behavior
with respect to Alice be
indistinguishable from from Bob and now
you can try to solve this problem and
and I guess yeah you could just hope
there's one non-trivial thing now that
you need to do which is a little weird
and I'm not sure anybody understands it
and in the language of SDP this is
related to things called pseudo
densities and pseudo expectations
there's a great theory of these things
being developed but it's still a bit
mysterious what's happening there right
in this form the constraints are too
complicated to be able to say something
about the entropy minimizer or the
relative entry minimizer so we do the
following we say we're trying to
approximate Bob by this K hapless Bob
who sort of does something very simple
Alice sent him a message and he looks at
K bits and superposition and make some
decision and therefore you know if
that's really the case so if if our
approximator was going to be k hapless
then it turns out that if you if you
sort of look at the in this you know
analysis test there's some coefficient
which is a function of X you can assume
that you can basically truncate all of
the high degree for a a mass of that
thing because if Bob only looks at K
bits in superposition then actually when
you when you trace when you take the
trace sort of you end up averaging over
all of these X's and Bob it will
actually be orthogonal to everything of
high-degree because ok well it's not
exactly clear but he's only looking at K
things at a time it turns out that Bob
can be written as a degree at most k
polynomial so now you can replace
although if you're really hoping to get
this k hapless bob approximation you can
replace all of the tests by low
dimensional tests okay so let's just
suppose you do that then okay and now
you solve this this problem so
everything was sort of formulaic we just
wrote down all the constraints
except for this weird step where we
truncated all the constraints and by the
way they're no longer measurements when
we truncate them now they're just
arbitrary symmetric matrices like
they're not you know they're not
positive they don't they don't yeah and
then you can compute the optimal
solution of this entropy maximization
problem okay and they one of the
beautiful things about entry
maximization is that like the optimal
solution the form of it is like you the
this optimal solution is written in
terms of the structure of the complaint
it could the constraints so for instance
here in this program we didn't specify
that the optimal solution should be a QC
state but it will be because all of the
tests are of QC form and what happens
here is basically since the since the
relative entropy of you know basically
Bob who were trying to approximate has
almost full entropy and therefore if you
think about this as a learning algorithm
it's impossible for the learning to
learn too much about Bob because there's
just not that much to learn
Bob doesn't have that much information
in him and that actually allows you to
bound the degree of the optimal solution
okay and then it turns out there's a
there's a problem here which is that the
degree you get is something like m
squared and this you know are changing
of the constraints only made sense if we
were going to get a degree M
approximation so so this M squared is
pretty bad let me just mention how we
okay the M squared is bad but it makes
sense because like basically there are
all these degree M things that bob is
sort of all of these tests that bob is
sort of learning about and then bob
builds his own you build your
approximator based on these tests so it
makes sense there's some overhead in
aggregating all of the information of
these tests into sort of an approximate
ER and the overhead is reflected in the
fact that we get something of degree M
squared okay so
but like our our our the whole thing
only made sense if Bob is M hapless if
he's M Squared hapless what we did
doesn't make sense so then this is where
the symmetry of the problem underlying
problem comes in this is why this only
works for polytopes where the vertices
are 0 1 to the N you know suppose you
have a chess grandmaster and you want
him to play against a bunch of chess
scrubs but it should be kind of slightly
interesting then what do you do well you
make him play against like a hundred
people at once and then even if even if
the chess grandmaster is like M Squared
hapless you know so like he's playing
with M Squared quality M Squared quality
split over so many games at some point
like you know he's gonna play one of the
games at a lower level I got to the hope
anyway when you when you set this up and
so that's actually how that's that's
that's actually exactly what we do here
so using the symmetry of the problem
this is not now we're running out of
time so but let's say yeah so you sort
of you basically do this on say instead
of doing it on on n variables do it on
every possible subset of routine
variables then you know Bob queries some
M Squared like you know Bob looks at
some M Squared bits but if I choose now
a random subset of the variables the
intersection of those variables know
down here you know like Bob is M Squared
hapless but here on this one game or on
a randomly chosen game actually he's
only querying some small set of the bits
not M Squared bits but much smaller
because it's sort of like you know the
intersection of this small set with a
random small set and so it turns out
that here you can construct the
approximator okay and this is really
where the symmetry of the problem comes
and that's why it only works for
polytopes where the vertices are 0 1 to
the N ok so that's a that works you get
an approximator now you've classified
the structure of the sort of general
communication protocols by query
protocols and therefore you connect the
you know general SDPs to a very special
class of SDPs for which we understand
things pretty well ok so that solves the
problem we were trying to solve now we
are to the last slide what happens you
know what's happening going forward so
first of all there have been
some interesting applications of this
Arum talked about one yesterday for
instance you can say that small STPs are
bad at solving the you know a
distinguishing separable states from
states that are far from separable this
application and in fact all of the
applications of the theorem i city here
so far are by reduction so far nobody
has opened up the the proof which i
think indicates that we don't really
understand exactly what's going on there
let me mention there are two open
problems which are both dying for people
with experience in quantum information
and quantum computation to to solve them
these are these are sort of like the the
most natural open problems one of them
is we don't know what happens for for
instance for the perfect matching
polytope it's still completely
consistent that there's a polynomial
size s DP for the perfect matching
polytope which would be a very very
interesting result for many reasons like
matching is in p so like there's no
there's no complexity theory prediction
that suggests this should or should not
happen and okay there's another open
problem which is to sort of our
techniques breakdown for approximation
problems at polynomial size to extend
these two exponential lower bounds but
really what i want to say is that these
open problems are there related to
basically the naivete of our
approximation procedure for instance
like we approximated bob but it's
totally natural that like why should you
just approximate bob why not also
approximate alice by say some simpler
alice and indeed in the linear
programming setting this was done
recently to make a really fantastic
progress but in general there's all
kinds of nice things for instance you
could ask you know like why can't you do
some kind of alternating minimization in
these types of things like you
approximate bob with respect to alice
and you get an approximated for bob and
then approximate alice with respect to
the approximator and you sort of like
you know there are they know sort of you
know and you get this kind of sequence
of approximations it makes sense that
sort of it's easier to approximate with
respect to a simpler adversary so like
this kind of alternating minimization
make sense that you might get something
better one area where I think it's this
is the last the last Pony to talk where
I think it might have a very nice effect
is in this long-standing open problem in
in communication complexity called the
log rank conjecture so in the paper for
your et al they said they showed that
for if you look at boolean communication
problems so it's this model of
communication expectation but now the
function is just zero one valued so just
trying to solve problems with zero one
values that the log-rank conjecture is
equivalent to the fact that any quantum
protocol can be simulated by a classical
protocol with only polynomial overhead
and what this suggests is something
really beautiful it would be nice if the
problem were solved in the following way
there's a you know sort of you know
there's a basically the log-rank
conjecture says that Alice and Bob have
some kind of protocol where they
exchange vectors and take inner products
but there's cancellations like the
vectors can you know there's you know
there's there are cancellations in the
like in the like classical cancellations
but you can simulate that what that what
the authors of this paper showed is that
you can simulate that with with with
quantum communication and this letter of
leads to this kind of really nice thing
which is that I think people probably
didn't think of in in the sort of the
classical complexity theory attic
setting that may be the right space of
for instance approximator x' of Alice
and Bob is in the space of even though
it's a completely classical
communication problem you're trying to
talk about maybe the right space of
approximations is in the quantum space
because maybe it's the case that like
every classical approximation is
actually very complex but there are
quantum approximations that are very
simple even though we tend to think of
quantum things as more complicated than
classical things in the sense of entropy
it's possible that there are quantum
approximate errors that are much more
simple it would be beautiful if you
could solve the law of great conjecture
by sort of approximating Alice and Bob
in the space of quantum protocols and
then once you have these simple
approximate errs now you can try to
convert them into classical protocols
with the idea being that the you know
the simplicity here has helped you in
the in the
step because you know a very specific
structure of the quantum approximator
and and the existence of quantum entropy
as a regularizer as a guide in this
optimization I mean it seems very
powerful because like in quantum you
have cancellations but still you have
positivity right it's sort of okay so
this is a very compelling approach and
hopefully one day someone can make it
work let me stop there thank you thank
you other questions for James
great to over here
great Ronald so what's your expectation
for matching polytope I well I expect
that the answer is that there is no
small semi definite program I know that
you have some partial results which
suggests something non-trivial is
happening but but but actually those
would be consistent with the fact that
there's a you know there's a polynomial
loss in the exponent here so I mean
something non-trivial is perhaps
happening there because I see yeah
because you guys have some something
non-trivial you can do with quantum
protocols for matchings I still think
that there's a there is no good lift is
DP left for the matching pollito but but
the major the major problem is that the
underlying set of vertices for the
matching polytope they're not it's not 0
1 to the N it's the space of perfect
matchings and these techniques for
various reasons fail miserably when you
go be out of zero sort of out of a
product space thank you there's a
question from Steve
um can you I didn't understand the
motivation for choosing the maximum
entropy estimate can you say maybe a few
words about that slide again please yeah
so let me just like that this is my
favorite thing I taught a course about
max entropy it's a simple idea it makes
sense if you have a bunch of
observations you maximize the entropy of
you're subject to those in sort of
satisfying those observations so in some
sense it makes sense that since you're
not overfitting you're gonna get
something simple like this might be the
simplest I guess the reason I'm asking
is because you you you do wind up
overfitting in a certain sense when you
use a maximum entropy estimation right
because you wind up with like a very
high rank estimate of a state like if
you think of other problems that have
natural SCP formulations like matrix
completion and things like this you use
an L 1 minimizer or you use like a least
squares minimizer with an L 1
regularization in order to get something
low rank which is in some sense simpler
so I'm trying to quit follow the know
the relevant notion of simple here like
I certainly agree a maximum entropy
estimate is simple in some philosophical
sense but I'm trying to understand if
it's sort of the right notion of simple
for this particular problem so this is
really about representations because
like so l1 minimization you know
encourages sparsity or low ranking or
low rank in the in the in the quantum
setting you know the but like you know
the the uniform distribution or the
maxima mixed state those are not sparse
they are there they are sparse if you
think about them in the right way so so
in fact you can use max entropy to get
sparse things but then you have to do
something like it's not naturally
encouraging sparsity especially really
it's you know if the constraints are not
sparse you don't necessarily like if the
constraints are saying you know
something dense about the space then you
don't expect that the entry Maximizer is
gonna be sparse but this philosophy with
the philosophy appears really powerful
like I have applied it in a few settings
form using like an additive number
where you just like you don't understand
what's happening but you just write down
your constraints and you maximize the
entropy and then you just like you get
results that took a like you know took
30 pages to prove in in five lines so I
could say but it's like it's become a
religion for me so and you get closed
form solutions which I guess was really
useful for this particular argument yeah
you have the power of convex programming
duality to get closed form solutions and
more than that you have the power of
gradient descent once you have a not you
can not yet once you have this regular
is it gives you a way to move around it
basically it makes the geometry of the
underlying space much nicer to move
around in
so in fact like to construct sparse
solutions you don't necessarily want to
take the Maximizer you just do gradient
descent and you show that say the
gradient update steps are simple and the
number of steps you need to get close is
small and then you get something sparse
that's one way to get getting sparse
thank you
few other questions I saw some hands
maybe that answered the questions any
other questions
okay well let's think James again for a
great talk
[Applause]